désolé pour le titre put à cliquer mais
c'est une question sérieuse
imaginez un musulman à quoi
ressemble-t-il je vais parler que la
réponse instinctive qui vous est venue
en tête c'est peut-être quelque chose
comme cette photo où celle là mais ces
photos sont elles représentatif de
l'ensemble des musulmans à travers le
monde
si je tire au hasard un humain sur terre
et si je vous dis que cet humain et
musulmans s probablement à ceux là qui
leur semble je vous invite à mettre
pause pour y réfléchir à quoi
faudrait-il davantage s'attendre
lorsqu'on pense un musulman
et pendant que vous réfléchissez il en
profite pour dire que cette vidéo n'a
absolument aucune visée politique
mon but est de montrer comment réfléchir
de manière bayésienne non seulement dans
des exemples théorique mais aussi dans
des exemples pratiques ou notre
hooliganisme nous empêche trop souvent
de vraiment prendre le temps de la
réflexion au calme et à tête reposée
[Musique]
on a tendance à penser que les musulmans
sont essentiellement arabes mais pour en
savoir plus je vous invite à aller voir
wikipedia et ça tombe bien il ya une
page qui s'appelle littéralement nombre
de musulmans par pays et étrangement
noms les plus grande population
musulmane n'habite pas le moyen orient
où l'afrique du nord ni à environ que 3
400 millions de musulmans dans cette
région ça fait beaucoup mais c'est en
fait bien moins que le nombre de
musulmans en asie en particulier les
plus grands pays musulmans sont en fait
l'indonésie le pakistan l'inde et le
bangladesh suivi ensuite du nigeria est
donc en fait le musulman le plus
classique sur terre il ressemble en fait
plutôt à ça ou ça voir ça qu'à ça
étrange non je vois avoir découvert ça
récemment et ça m'a vraiment surpris je
me suis sentie à la fois très ignorants
et très incompétents n'y aura pas ce que
je ne le savais pas et incompétents
parce que j'étais pourtant très sûr de
mon préjugés erronés sur la population
musulmane mondiale
d'ailleurs on peut voir les chiffres en
pourcentage et voir que 62% des
musulmans vivent en asie et selon cet
autre tableau la plupart viennent bien
des régions autour de l'inde et de
l'indonésie
puisqu'on y trouve 30 % et 13 % de la
population musulmane mondiale n'en
trouve aussi trois pour cent dans l'asie
centrale et 3% dans l'asie de l'est
selon ces chiffres la partie
moyen-orient afrique du nord ne contient
en fait que 27% des musulmans sur terre
alors qu'il y en a aussi 16% en afrique
subsaharienne puis enfin on en trouve 2
7% en europe et quelques boîtes ailleurs
bon bien sûr tous ces chiffres sont à
prendre avec des pincettes car tous les
musulmans n'ont pas exactement les mêmes
croyances
il ne croit pas tout à fait au même
islam wikipedia explique ainsi que les
pourcentages indiqué de témoigner ni de
la pratique régulière la ritualité ni de
la fois individuelle la religiosité des
personnes se déclarant musulmanes mais
plutôt de leur attachement à l'islam en
tant que composante culturelle et
historique de leur identité
bref la religion c'est compliqué d'après
un sondage du journal le monde
17% des français qui se déclarent
catholiques déclare en fait ne pas
croire en dieu et ils sont aussi 26% à
déclarer qu'il n'y a rien après la mort
comme l'expliquent christophe michel
dans ce super épisode de vortex c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un se présente
d'une certaine religion
qu'ils adhèrent et qu ils cochent toutes
les cases du départ rouge
le vatican par exemple le catéchisme n'a
beaucoup de préjugés instinctif sur les
religions ainsi que sur ceux qui se
déclarent religieux mais attention au
degré de validité de ces préjugés
nous fondons souvent nos préjugés
instinctif à partir d' images qui nous
sont véhiculés or le marché de
l'information dans les médias dans la
vie quotidienne ou sur les réseaux
sociaux favorisent des informations plus
pita clic et virale qui corresponde
typiquement à des informations exagérées
caricaturer voir manichéenne surtout
dans certains médias dans certaines
sphères sociales et sur certains réseaux
sociaux mais ce n'est pas tout il faut
aussi prêté attention au degré de
validité de ces préjugés sur un individu
religieux en particulier
certes la plupart des catholiques sont
croyants mais visiblement tous ceux qui
se déclarent catholiques ne sont pas
croyants
donc si vous parlez à quelqu'un qui
s'identifient à une religion il serait
bien trop précipitée et potentiellement
malencontreux de conclure qu'il croit
forcément en dieu en particulier s'il
vous dit qu'il ne croit pas en dieu il
serait fallacieux de persister à croire
qu'il croit en dieu
l'information qui vous a donnée devrait
déplacer vos curseur de turing est en
l'occurrence il devrait complètement le
déplacer en fait si vous prenez un
religieux au hasard du fait qu'il soit
religieux ne vous dit pas tout de cette
personne
loin de là malgré cette information vous
devriez persiste et avoir une grande
incertitude sur le faciès les habitudes
et même les croyances de cette personne
et vous devriez être prêt à ajuster vos
crédence en fonction de nouvelles
informations au sujet de cette personne
est bien sûr tout ce que je dis là sur
la religion est valable pour tout autre
aspect de la personne comme son genre
son origine ou son faciès
tiens en parlant de faciès pourquoi
est-ce qu'on se trompe tant vis-à-vis du
faciès probable d'un musulman
pourquoi notre préjugés instinctif en ce
à quoi ressemble un musulman est il si
erronée alors oui comme on l'a vu il ya
un cliché plus souvent partagée du
musulman que d'autres en tout cas en
france on parle finalement très peu en
france des musulmans indonésiens ou
pakistanais mais il me semble que la
confusion entre musulmans et arabes a
potentiellement un autre fondement à
savoir cet horrible confusion entre la
vraisemblance des données et la crédence
des théories je ne le répéterai jamais
assez mais la vraisemblance des données
n'est pas la crédence 2
théorie ou plus généralement la
probabilité de à sa jambe et n'est pas
la probabilité de b sachant à pour le
comprendre on peut ressortir le tableau
de wikipédia n'est-il pas un truc qui
vous paraît étrange quelque chose qui
distingue le moyen orient de l'asie et
de l'afrique subsaharienne dans les pays
arabes
la très grande majorité des habitants
sont musulmans ou dit autrement en
langage parisien la probabilité qu'un
individu soit musulman sachant qu'il est
arabe est proche de 1 ou 10 encore
autrement si un individu est arabe
alors il est probablement musulmans
cependant il ne faut pas confondre ces
informations avec la probabilité inverse
à savoir la probabilité d'être arabes
sachant qu'on est musulman en
particulier le fait qu'un arabe et
probablement musulmans n'implique
absolument pas le fait qu'un musulman et
probablement arabe
la probabilité de à sachant b n'est pas
la probabilité de b sachant a en
particulier dans notre cas non la
probabilité qu'un individu sous arabes
sachant qu'il est musulman n'est pas
proche de 1
en effet comme on l'a vu sachant qu'un
individu est musulman cet individu est
plus probablement d'asie du sud ou
d'asie du sud est
il ressemble plus probablement à sa ou à
ça qu'il ne ressemble à ça même si un
arabe et probablement musulmans un
musulman est en fait probablement pas
arabe ou dit de manière plus fréquente
east la plupart des arabes sont
musulmans mais la plupart des musulmans
ne sont pas arabes
cette distinction entre la probabilité
de haas a changé et la probabilité de
bessat champ à est vraiment critique à
comprendre pour progresser dans la
compréhension du bail à nice mme en
particulier en remplaçant musulmans
pardonner et arabes par théorie on en
vient à conclure qu'une donnée peut
parfaitement être expliquée par une
théorie mais que cette théorie peut ne
pas être crédible sachant la donner la
grande vraisemblance des données ne
suffit pas à rendre la théorie crédible
car la vraisemblance des données n'est
pas la crédence de la théorie pour
vraiment saisir cette distinction
cruciale au plus profond de vous même je
vous invite vivement à longuement médité
l'exemple des musulmans et des arabes
jusqu'à ce que la distinction entre la
probabilité qu'un musulman soit rab et
la probabilité qu'un arabe soit musulman
soit limpide dans votre tête vous y
réfléchissez
vous arrivez à trouver comment clarifier
tout ça dans votre tête
ok parce qu'on va maintenant essayer
d'aller plus loin en essayant de
comprendre la cause de cette distinction
pourquoi ces deux probabilités sont
elles différentes comment est ce
possible que la plupart des érables soit
musulman mais que la plupart des
musulmans ne soient pas arabe
quelle est l'explication bayésienne à ce
paradoxe apparent
comprendre de façon bayésienne la
distinction entre les arabes
probablement musulmans et les musulmans
probablement pas arabe
ce sont les préjugés et oui je vais
finir une vidéo sur les arabes et les
musulmans en défendant les préjugés cher
algorithmes de youtube
je te promets que ma vidéo est purement
éducatif et qu'elle ne cherche pas à
aggraver des polarisation politique s'il
te plaît ne considère pas que cette
vidéo est politique bien sûr quand je
parle de préjugés je ne parle pas de
préjugés instinctif auxquelles on n'a
pas réfléchi on l'a vu nos préjugés
instinctif sont fortement empoisonné par
beaucoup de pollution informationnelle
surtout sur des sujets clivants ou
controversés et là on parle d'un sujet
un peu clivant et controversés dans ces
cas il faut absolument beaucoup se
méfier de nous préjugés instinctif mais
ce n'est pas de ces préjugés instinctif
que je parle aujourd'hui
non ici je parle des préjugés au sens
bayésiens autrement dit qu'aurait-on du
sujet avant d'avoir collecté des données
qu'aurait-il était rationnel de préjugés
dans notre cas la donne et correspond au
fait que l'individu est musulman cette
donnée est crucial pour savoir à quoi
ressemble l'individu mais pour penser de
manière parisienne il est indispensable
de prendre le temps de d'abord ignoré la
donner et de réfléchir à ce qu'il
fallait penser avant d'apprendre la
donner avant de savoir la religion de
l'individu que pouvait-on penser de son
faciès
à quoi ressemble un individu a priori
quel est le préjugé bayésiens à avoir
sur le visage d'un humain
et bien si cet humain est tiré au hasard
dans la population humaine
il en fait beaucoup de chances de
ressembler à ça ou à ça oui parce que
plus de la moitié des humains sur terre
sont typés asiatiques comme moi ou
indiens pakistanais bangladesh en effet
il ya presque 4 milliards de tels
individus sur terre c'est beaucoup plus
que les 4 500 millions d'arabes ses
environs lui fois plus
autrement dit comme 8 est égale à deux
puissances 3 sur le curseur de turing a
priori on est à trois bits en faveur
d'asiatiques du sud ou de l'est pas en
position à arabe
on a là un préjugé justifié est
extrêmement marqué en faveur d'un
individu d'asie du sud ou de l'est
maintenant que ce préjugé a été assez
bien calculer on peut ensuite passer à
la mise à jour du curseur de turing en
exploitant la donner a prises
la donnée est le fait que l'individu est
musulman pour savoir comment déplacer le
curseur
il nous faut alors calculer le rapport
de surprise à quel point cette donnée et
elle surprenante selon les deux théories
pour un individu d'asie du sud ou de
l'est
la donnée cet individu est musulman est
assez surprenante mais elle en fait
aussi très loin d'être délirante
en effet un tiers des asiatiques du sud
et de l'est sont musulmans on est donc
surpris d'un facteur 3 par opposition
plus de 90% des arabes sont musulmans
pour un arabe la donne et il est
musulman n'est pas surprenante
elle n'est pas garanti car de nombreux
arabes ne sont pas musulmans mais elle
est très probable a priori dès lors le
rapport de surprises qui dit à quel
point on est davantage surpris dans le
premier cas que dans le second est donc
égale à environ 3 ce qui est entre 2 et
4 or 2 correspond à un beat et 4
correspond à 2 beat donc 3 correspond à
quelque chose comme un beat et demi
voilà qui nous pousse à déplacer le
curseur de turing d'un bit avait omis en
faveur de la théorie rab de façon
cruciale ce déplacement du curseur de
turing est alors bien plus faible que le
préjugé justifier que l'on avait
initialement
au final le curseur de turing fini à 1
bit et demi en faveur de asie du sud ou
de l'est contre arabe
autrement dit d'après nos calculs
l'individu à trois fois plus de chances
d'être d'asie du sud ou de l'est que
d'être rap
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé certes
informations l'individu et musulmans à
déplacer notre curseur de tueries vers
la théorie arabe
cependant ceci ne suffit absolument pas
à conclure que l'individu est
probablement arabe
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait un préjugé
justifié et marqué à avoir sur le faciès
de l'individu avant que l'on sache
qu'ils soient musulmans quand les
préjugés sont justifiables mans marqué
et j'insisterai sans doute jamais assez
sur l'importance du mot justifiable le
mans alors la probabilité de à sa
chambre et peut être radicalement
différente de la probabilité de b
sachant à et c'est vraiment le calcul de
ce préjugé marquer
qui est souvent extrêmement déficient en
pratique on a tendance à s'appuyer
davantage sur des préjugés instinctif
qui sont empoisonnés par la pollution
informationnelle ou parfois même souvent
en sciences a préféré ignorer le fait
qu'il puisse exister des préjugés
justifié dès lors on est parfois amené à
croire que la vraisemblance des données
est forcément similaire à la crédence de
la théorie mais en présence de préjugés
justifia blement marqué la vraisemblance
des données sera potentiellement très
différente de la crédence de la théorie
et en particulier dans notre cas ça nous
amène à conclure que oui un arabe et
probablement musulmans mais non un
musulman n'est probablement pas arabe
hier fois j'avais parlé des intervalles
de crédence à vous avez encouragé à
parier sur les intervalles de crédence
sur toutes sortes de nombre que vous
croisez dans votre quotidien
j'insiste à nouveau dessus c'est
vraiment un effort pédagogiquement très
instructif à faire donc je vous invite
vraiment à faire l'effort de paris
régulièrement des intervalles de
créances pour que ce soit plus stimulant
encore intellectuellement pôle emploi
propose d'en faire des vrais paris c'est
à dire que typiquement vous allez
proposer des intervalles de crédence un
ami avec une cote qui correspond au
degré de crédence de votre intervalle
donc typiquement si vous avez un
intervalle de crédence à 95%
alors ça revient à proposer à votre ami
un pari avec une cote à 95 contre 5 est
votre ami peut accepter ou non cet
intervalle de créances que vous proposez
s'il accepte pareil ça va typiquement
dire qu'il pense que votre intervalles
est trop restreint et qui ne contient
pas assez de valeur et que du coup il ya
le projet était supérieure à 5% que la
donnée sorte de votre intervalle de
crédence vous invite vivement à ces de
mettre ça en pratique un plan blanc
propose même un incitatif économique a
joué seul ordures par exemple donner de
l'argent ou 2 donc bon vous trouvez une
troisième personne prête à donner
d'argent ou deux personnes pour faire ce
genre de paris mais vous invite vraiment
à le faire en pratique parce que ça
permet vraiment de mieux mesurer notre
excès de confiance qui est vraiment
quelque chose de critiques et sur
lesquels on est très défaillant en
pratique
et une fois qu'on a mieux corriger nos
excès de confiance ça permet aussi de
mesurer l'étendue de notre ignorance qui
a également beaucoup d'intérêt pratique
à nome force lui fait la remarque que
dans le cas de thibault n'y a d'autres
qui est l'exemple que j'ai donnée lors
de la vidéo précédente pour pouvoir
construire des intervalles de crédence
aussi aux petits mots que possible aussi
restreint que possible ils prennent en
compte toutes les informations que l'on
a pour être aussi restreint que possible
tout en restant à 95% de crédence eh
bien on pouvait faire des études de
toutes sortes de données notamment bas
quelle est l'évolution de du montant
collecté par t-bone ya deux au cours du
temps alors j'avoue que j'ai pas du tout
les données historiques donc c'est un
peu compliqué mais si on en croit ces
données on a l'impression que c'est une
courbe qui attend ça se rappela tir au
fur et à mesure ce qui est quelque chose
de tout à fait prévisible et si on
prolonge cette courbe
on s'attend sans doute à quelque chose
autour de cent mille euros qui seront
collectés par tube onu à 2 j'imagine
s'il donne à l'internât de créances
entre 90 milles et disons sont trente
mille avec crédence 95% l'on en croit
cette extrapolation
après il faut faire gaffe parce que sur
ce genre de choses il peut y avoir
parfois des déclics peut-être canton
daniel de faire une vidéo et du coup ça
va faire exploser le truc est pire que
ça le seul genre de déclic peut faire
des effets boule de neige qui peut
surtout amplifié
c'est pour ça que me semble probable
qu'il n'y ait pas de couscous non il ya
comme une probabilité qui ne me semble
pas si négligeable qu'il y ait cet effet
de boule de neige avec quelque chose qui
devient un peu fou tout à coup et si
c'est le cas le montant collecté pour a
explosé tout à coup alors ce qu'on a ce
genre d'effet boule de neige on a
souvent des distributions qui sont non
plus ce sont des lois normales ou quasi
normales mais on a souvent ce qu'on
appelle des distributions 1 que épaisse
de distribution pas moi qui ai inventé
le nom et dans ce genre de cas en fait
la probabilité des événements extrêmes
n'est généralement pas aussi faible que
ce qu'on pourrait croire
a priori on va donc il ya sans doute un
peu d'incertitude sur les valeurs
extrêmes du montant qui sera collecté
par t-bone ya 2 du coup si je devais
parier rien faire avec 95 %
je pense que ça serait vraiment quelque
chose comme entre 90 mille et trois
mille vous prenez le pari à 95 contre 5
enfin un dernier truc à dire sur ces
intervalles de 15 ans c'est qui
évolue à chaque fois que vous avez des
nouvelles informations et en particulier
là je suis en train de filmer cette
vidéo deux semaines avant que vouloir
regarder quelque chose comme ça du coup
vous avez beaucoup plus d'informations
que moi du coup on fait le pari est pas
tout à fait équitable mais ça vient tout
simplement du fait que chacun d'entre
nous a une vision subjective parce qu'il
a ses propres données et en particulier
les prédictions du mois d'il ya deux
semaines ont envoyé cette vidéo ne sont
pas les mêmes que les prédictions du
mois maintenant il est clair que
j'allais mais cette vidéo j'avais dit
que je parlerai du principe de
précaution
en fait non je trouve très décalé ça à
la prochaine vidéo de vue que j'ai eu
quelques retours comme quoi les gars
vidéo était pas caché qu'ils vous siégez
concept un peu compliqué et qu'elle
avait aussi mon début je voulais faire
un truc à la fois plus plus ta clique
mais également qui revient un peu plus
au fondement du bail à nice et notamment
cette distinction entre profiter de
grâce à tomber et la probité de b
sachant à et de façon plus générale
j'aimerais vous proposer d'autres outils
pour père du mécanisme pragmatique et
justement la prochaine fois on va avoir
une autre vidéo dans ce genre on va
parler encore fait de l'importance des
préjugés en parlant notamment du
problème des croyances orpheline
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et avait commenté à partager
pensez à vous abonner tonton et
visionnent merci au petit bard de leur
dos et j'espère que je serai là
la prochaine fois on appelle cette
erreur le sophisme du procureur c'est un
raisonnement très classique parce que
c'est exactement le raisonnement qui est
tenu dans chaque étude scientifique avec
analyse statistique fréquentes east un
test l'hypothèse le calcul d'une
vraisemblance la valeur p et le rejet de
l'hypothèse nul si on part de
l'hypothèse qu'elle est innocente deux
morts subites du nourrisson d'affilée ce
serait trop invraisemblable une chance
sur 73 millions
on en déduit donc que on peut rejeter
l'hypothèse de son innocence
dans l'hypothèse où elle est réellement
coupable et bien c'est sûr que les
victimes sont mortes
c'est 100 % mais en vérité ce n'est pas
exactement ces chiffres là qu'il nous
faut nous faire une opinion sur la
culpabilité
si on raisonne de façon bayésienne il
faut plutôt calculer la probabilité
qu'elle soit coupable d'infanticide
sachant que ces deux bébés sont morts
vous voyez celle inverse
ça c'est la plausibilité de sa
culpabilité
et china gas gas qui pour 34 90